okay welcome back our next speaker is
Abba gomel Abba is just moved to uh the
University of Maryland uh he is one so
that's nice for me because now I can
just say he's a chair at the University
of Maryland before he had sort of five
different name chairs which I wouldn't
remember so ABBA is actually the main
organizer of this conference he I think
he he sort of inherited that because the
main actual main organizer called
coveted couldn't
do the end so ABBA is actually
organizing this thank you ABBA for
inviting Abba which we now hear
[Laughter]
yes okay I'd like to thank myself for
inviting myself to be a speaker I know I
I think the conference is um we invited
up the real organizers are being a
Christian I mean it's a fantastic job in
putting it together anyway uh thank you
all for coming my
modeling focusing more on the the
modeling side of things and some of the
lessons that we've learned uh from well
we're still lucky and how we might
possibly mitigate the next pandemic
unfortunately I have to start on this uh
pessimistic
um
tone that the question of pandemics of
the likes of covert is a question of
when and not if
when the next one is hitting us not to
give the next one and I'll explain uh
why that's the the case anyway so the
focus is basically to summarize some of
the lessons that we learned focusing
mostly on some of the work that we and
some others have done and some in this
room
um and and how best we can try to be
together next one uh when it hits okay
and a lot of people I need to thank and
funding agencies so msri funded our our
joint working group on coverage uh I was
supposed to we're supposed to work on
malaria but because it's 2020
so it changed to covert and the NSF of
course for funding our research and
Science Foundation I'm Affiliated to the
University of Pretoria Department of
Mathematics and Applied Mathematics and
we've got funding from the national
Research Foundation of South Africa as
well okay so but at the very beginning I
always like to start these Talks by
mentioned in the the pioneers of
mathematical or the his history of
infectious disease modeling going back
to Daniel Bernoulli's work on
immunization against smallpox in the
1760s and smallpox happened happens to
be one of only two vaccine preventable
diseases that we have eradicated the
second one being render faster
so that was very influential work I
think that was probably the first
mathematical model designed in uh and
use
try to provide insight into what's going
on as then Sereno roses work uh first he
was the first to show that plasmodium
causes malaria
and he won the Nobel Prize in 1902 for
that work but I think from the
mathematical modeling Community he's
more known for uh establishing the
threshold theory of epidemics so uh
control malaria we didn't have to kill
all mosquitoes all you need to do is
bring the number of mosquitoes below a
certain threshold and you have a good
chance to yeah
one of his media so I would give the the
credit to the whole notion of are not
going back to Sarah morose's idea of
threshold okay you don't have to kill
realistically you cannot kill all
mosquitoes so I said why it's called are
not
ah Ross Ross okay great I like that
that's why it's called are not yeah yeah
probably no um
that's a good point actually I haven't
thought of that maybe it's because no he
didn't call it or not he just said
that's a threshold so mosquito abundant
just bring the mosquito abundance down
below a certain threshold and you have a
good chance to eradicate or eliminate
mother
and then of course uh comic mechanic I'm
very glad ATM mentioned in his
presentation yesterday the comic
mckendrick uh mathematical theory of
epidemic it's not just sir models the
the formulated thing in general really
uh really excellent papers um so this
site of them here
um anyway so they laid the foundation
for mathematical City and notice none of
them really is a mathematician one of
the findings are except maybe with
counter Bernoulli is a mathematician
but the others are not and they laid the
the foundation the medical people there
but you know by Commerce and
epidemiologists and yeah and so on so
but that's the uh fundamental work done
at the early stages of mathematical
modeling of infectious diseases
okay so it's a collaboration between
mathematicians and Public House people
and when I say Public House people
talking about epidemiologists ecologists
clinicians also the people that are
involved in from the biological point of
view of controls diseases so it's a
collaboration between mathematical
scientists and mathematical scientists
to me means mathematicians
statisticians computer scientists and so
on that use mathematical approaches to
understand the spread of diseases and
how best to control them so Public
Health people have their own wish list
who are in early stages or outbreaks of
diseases so early estimation of
epidemiological thresholds for example
like are not so are not meaning roses
not sure so I like that new definition
now so early estimation or basic
reproduction number or hot
Administration which I'll talk about a
little later or disease burden was
expected number of people to to be
infected or that will be hospitalized or
that will unfortunately die of the
disease that kind of
um so maybe yesterday we had talks this
custom final size of the epidemic right
so
so determining qualitative nature of the
spread of the disease and so on an
assessment of control studies we had a
very good talk this morning about
testing and then contact tracing
yesterday as well all of these things uh
they cost effective in minimizing the
burden of the epidemic especially when
you have limited resources limited
allocation of those reasons
so that's the public households but then
we're mathematicians or mathematical
scientists so we have our own wish list
and so what we do is we in interaction
with the public health people design
mathematical models that provide some
insight into what's going on but we also
have our interests in trying to
determine the qualitative properties of
this model so it typically existence and
that's very stability of the solutions
of the model and maybe do some
modifications and that's the reason we
do the verification analysis because it
tells us in parameter space under what
conditions do we reach persistence or
elimination of the disease or effective
control of the disease so they are
there's also statistical components so
we collect data we fit the data uh
models to the data and then
um to estimate and non-parameters and
then make predictions afterwards and
maybe study also the impact of
uncertainty uh in the estimates of the
parameters on the outcome of the
simulations that we have so so all sort
of interest from mathematical
statistical and even computational point
of view I mean some people use
computational intensive large-scale
models like
agent-based models for example Network
models uh that require High uh
computational power and so on
okay
so there are different types of models
focused mostly on compartmental modeling
but others I think yesterday we talked
about meta population models fashion
models
agent based depending on the type of
model you choose to use in times of
epidemics depends on the uh the kind of
question you want to address and also
the type of data that you have available
I think so if for example the question
is to determine who impacted whom then
it makes a lot of sense to use
agent-based modeling right
to use but for most of my purposes I
think compartmental modeling seems to be
adequate so typically we split the total
population into mutually exclusive
compartments based on disease status and
it could be deterministic could be
stochastic time or delay differential
equation type stuff
all right
but anyway the type of model you choose
really depends on the kind of questions
you want to address and the level of
data if it's uh if you have really
detailed data then agent-based model may
be
but so question whether you can have the
level of data needed to really come up
with good agent-based models but
this is something we can debate later
okay so a simple sir mechanic uh special
kit of this comic mechanic formulation
is given by this so as it's acceptable
eyes infected R is recovered or removed
and this is for an epidemic which means
a disease that we have not seen before
no one has prior immunity so the only
thing that can happen to a susceptible
person after interaction with someone in
I class is for some potential for
infection if that happens at right beta
then the subtle most of the eye class
and the only thing that can happen in
the iclass is the infected person can
recover at the rate gamma and move to
the R Class the solution curves clearly
so it's acceptable depleted a little bit
but not all susceptible people get
infected so infection reaches a peak and
comes down and dies down to zero on the
most of the all all the impacted people
recover eventually and that's basically
so this is this model has just one
equilibrium or line of equilibria
actually
um given by this and there's no
bifurcation here regardless what are not
is the disease dies out according to
this formulation right that's the
underlying assumption disease common
goals are affecting every member of the
community that's one of the main
conclusions from the comic mechanic
formulation
and
yeah and that's no bifurcation so even
if I don't know is greater than one the
disease dies out eventually
and this is widely used uh to model the
plague and cholera in different settings
uh the key assumptions okay this uh
homogeneous mixing we talked about that
yesterday a lot
um exponentially distributed waiting
times in all epidemiological
compartments
large populations therefore it can be
deterministic it doesn't have to be
stochastic it's a small population then
stochasticity is important uh permanent
natural immunity once you recover you
never get it again so it's like shingles
or a chickenpox for example you get it
you don't get it again until later on
you have you have shingles
the time scale of the disease is assumed
to be much much smaller than the
demographic time scale so that you do
not have to include
birth and death processes here so that's
another so there's so many assumptions
so the reason I'm spending time on this
is I mean the you know models are
basically the you know the output of
models depends on what you import I mean
what you put in so what you put in a
initial data but also the assumptions in
the design of the model so the
assumptions if you make a lot and
homogeneous I mean everybody is equally
likely to mix with everybody else in the
community and acquire infection from
that so
based on this assumption now we we can
make predictions but anyway the point is
that you know there are models are there
also models so it depends on
the assumptions you you make in the
formulation mode
so for any questions this stage no okay
all right uh of course this is a
simplistic possible model maybe one can
use and in fact this you can show that
this reduces actually a simple logistic
equation
um so DX DT equals Alpha X plus one
minus X and that's why the early stages
of an epidemic simple equations like
logistic equations can pick the data
quite well this this one is essential
logistic equation
okay so but this of course you can
extend to add all sorts of heterogenitis
like age structure like wrist structure
spatial structure mixing structure
various interventions
multiple variants evolutionary aspect
climate change
as the nurses
and all sorts of things I can
incorporate
the more heterogeneity you add to the
model because the more complex it
becomes and in some cases it becomes
less mathematical mathematically
tractable if you do that there's always
a trade-off right you're adding
heterogeneity you adding you're making
models more realistic uh biologically
epidemiologically but mathematically not
much probably can be done in terms of
analysis
but again it depends on the questions
you want to address
okay so now I want to talk about art now
this is really important we we talked
yesterday I understand there was a
discussion I don't know a few weeks ago
maybe on what is the real definition of
R naught so I so the classical
definition is that's an index case here
and so black uh people who are not
someone infected so the index scale is
the very first case so if in this case r
naught is two so they're not in R naught
is completely susceptible population
meaning no one in the population has
prior immunity no vaccination no
quarantine no intervention whatsoever so
that's the notch zero here means is that
so this is a completely acceptable
population you introduce a single case
if R naught is two then this person
transmitted two others and this guy
transmitted to others and so on before
you know it all black will come red
this is a completely vulnerable
population and the spreading and there's
no Public Health intervention and no one
has prohibited and the second case is if
you have uh control episodes RC
controller production number where there
are some people in blue those are people
that have prior immunity either they've
been vaccinated or they have sensitive
disease before and recovered from it so
they have some protection they are not
completely as susceptible as those in
Black you know and that's the control
production number and are not
mathematically speaking it's a specular
radius of some metrics so let me quickly
show what that means so for example if
we have a simple Model S dot equals Pi
minus beta s i or n minus mu s this
natural death rate is born epidemic and
that's E-class uh which is the exposed
class basically people who just got
infected but they're not yet infectious
and mu is natural destroy Sigma is one
over Sigma is essentially the incubation
period so uh
say gamma is the capital rage mu is
natural desperate and Delta is to this
District that's right
minus the same UI and suppose for this
set is the scir model
uh for this basic scr model uh if you
recover you do not get you don't become
susceptible again so here are not
classically is always in fraction rate
near the disaster equilibrium
okay near dfp
times average duration of infections it
starts how long
you are able to infect people up average
duration
of infectiousness okay
um so what does that mean so if I'm
infectious
okay what's my rate of impacting
susceptible people so it's this guy here
this coefficient but neither this is
pretty equilibrium again because this
person is introduced at a population
that is basically a disease-free
equilibrium except except for that
person
so that's why when you compute R naught
it's near the digital equilibrium so
it's beta s star
divided by answer and okay and this is
free equilibrium here
equilibrium is one you set the right
hand side to zero so that this
equilibrium has you know is given by
this a style just to indicate
so this will be in the absence of
disease this guy is zero at equilibrium
that zero so five minus v s is zero so
this is
equilibrium we are at the current
capacity Pi by mu
um so the infraction rate is my ability
to infect if I'm in I is given by Beta
but I'm infecting only the proportion of
the population that are currently
susceptible which is s of T divided by n
of T but at the digital equilibrium so
beta s double n so in this case s t and
n star equals one right because M Star
is s Star Plus a star plus I star
so n is the total population is S Plus e
plus I plus r so that's infection right
now that is this for equilibrium time
the average duration of infectiousness
okay so my duration of infectiousness is
here is one divided how long I stay in
the I class because of the exponentially
distributed waiting time it's one over
gamma
plus b plus Delta you can see if you
solve this I dot minus this term if it
equals if you only consider this you see
this is an exponential distribution was
mean one over gamma plus V plus Delta
but in order for me to go to the iCloud
I have to survive the E class so what's
the probability the probability of
surviving the E class is Sigma divided
by Sigma plus mean so I've survived the
if I've transmitted this to someone in s
there's someone in s is now in E and
they have to survive the E Class to go
to I what's this probability and once
they're in I how long can they transmit
interaction is one over a gamma plus
yeah meaning they didn't uh they didn't
die while in e or they didn't leave
quality so yeah yeah so they survived
the incubation period so you got
impacted today there is a timeline
before you can start transmitting so
it's about for covert initially was like
12 days the later it was changed over
5.1 days so you survive that period but
you didn't die okay so you're still
impacted you didn't uh you didn't
recover so you go to the I class after
that very good so that's R naught so s
and I N will cancel out that's R naught
but it also can be obtained using the
Next Generation operator method so what
we need to do is just find two matrices
so you see this infection rate near this
equilibrium is the Matrix f
and this average duration of
infectiousness is actually the inbound
because how long you stay in the
compartment is one divided by the sum of
the linear rates leaving that
compartment so it's essentially the
inverse
the inverse of the Matrix so f is the
Matrix of new infection terms so
basically and we only care about the E
and I so what what's that okay so look
at the so if this is e this is I here so
the new infections in the E-class is
basically beta s t which is a
coefficient of I so it's this zero here
there's no
individuals in e-cloud neural transmit
infections so this is but those in
the eye Class 2 at this rate near DFE
beta a star over n and in the I class
there are no need infections nothing in
beta so everything is zero here so you
have this two by two and then the
inverse the V Matrix is the Matrix of
the linear transition terms leaving the
impacted compartments or coming into the
impact so this one is so here we change
the size so it's Sigma plus mu this is
again e and I
uh for e and there's nothing in I that's
linear
in the first equation the second
equation this is Sigma for e but we
change the sign that's the North
American notation and the European
notation so I'm sticking with the
European rotate they know the American
notation and then this is gamma plus mu
you just change the sign
uh and are not this expression we got
will be equivalent to
this the spectral radius of this Matrix
they'll they'll be so you find the
eigenvalues of FV inverse there will be
two of them one is zero the other one is
non-zero which would be exactly that
so so that's the yeah so that's the
sorry uh
yeah so a row of yeah
for the computer
yeah so so Matt this is it this is it
really is it in the dominant eigenvalue
one I think was discussing yeah
yeah the question uh so this uh oh sorry
uh so this is really great so the the
way I usually think about the way you've
written down the equations for seir is
like a deterministic system and then the
latter way you found the basic
reproduction number is based on this
Stickman method and yeah that works
always for the deterministic system when
you can work it out but your first so
the first way you derived it you're all
of a sudden interpreting that as if it
were the stochastic case and doing it
all in terms of expectations right so
essentially yeah the the first part the
first way I did it was by inspection or
Not by inspection it's not by using
linearity right just following the
infection so if I'm here how many new
cases am I going to generate during my
lifetime of infectiousness yes so the
first one right it was it seemed a
little heuristic but yeah it could be
made formal if everything has the
expected value is under this stochastic
interpretation I like that yeah yeah uh
but so when do you know when they
actually agree uh they agree here right
I didn't check that but I would yeah I
think for me this is classical different
this is a classical definition Arnold is
my ability to transmit infection to
someone and how long I'm able to do it
the product of the two of us are always
my contagion capacity my capacity
transmitted infection times how long I'm
able to do it
yeah that's that's basically it so if
this agrees with the stochastic
formulation that would be fantastic yeah
if I didn't check that but that's a very
good point yeah that's great
where are you at discussion Monday a
week ago about or not I see so this is
exactly it's a discussion we discussed
for
90 minutes and we decided you could
discuss for another week so the answer
is it's actually very non-obvious in
this General's case how to even Define
it correctly yeah we should have that
discussion again please Greg
I just have a comment so one way in
which you can think about it is the sort
of classical deterministic sir equation
you can think about it as a master
equation for certain stochastic process
and if you do that this actually turns
out that those two are equivalent to
finish
but there's also the notion of Target
and type of production number
so uh this matrices I mean you can the
way you generate them could be different
depending on what you enter into app and
what you intend to be sometimes like so
we had a paper on color so we had like
four or five different production
numbers and depending on what is this is
an M Matrix right it so it has this the
diagonal elements are always none uh
non-negative so they're always positive
and the up diagonal are non-positive
so that's an M Matrix so you can take
into you can use some of the theories of
parents theorem like a positive matrices
based on the structure of this way and
this is a strictly positive Matrix no
it's a it's a non-negative matrix they
have of new infection it's a
non-negative matrix of new infection
terms and this is the m Matrix of linear
transition terms so it's just like
follow the money here we follow the
infection when you do the next
generation of protagon method this is
the method by order Dickman and hysteric
and meth in the 1990 early 90s yeah and
then presented in a simplified version I
think this is a very theoretical paper
fantastic paper
or presented in a simpler way so already
if you have let's say two types males
and females and different sort of let's
say you have AIDS and males and females
and homosexuals and non homosexuals and
you have sort of types this is still the
correct definition but it's very hard to
give already then it's not you can't
just choose a random member of the
population initial case that will give
you a different number it's a wrong
number and this
this leading eigenvalue is the correct
number and there's some way to make it
the same but you already have to think a
little and it's a more complicated the
model is the more you have to think to
get a reasonable or not yeah so it is so
it says the average number of new case
the Gen the definitions average number
of new cases generated by a typical
impacted individual introducing a
completely susceptible but typical not
ever impacted because if I'm super
spreader I mean in fact 100 but I mean
in fact two Christian may impact one you
know so so Json in fact Amelia for
example I like this so so that is so
that's why we take the average the
typical you know so in the definition
we're very careful to say it's a
difficult not not ever impacted
individual whether you take for the
average of the average number of new
cases generated by a typical infectious
individual introducing a completely
susceptible population
anyway sorry really really important
that what typical infectious individual
a typical individual who is infected is
not a typical or infectious individual
absolutely yeah
he has a long discussion there's a
typical infectious individualist after
one step of the infection or after 100
or however it takes to stabilize yeah
and if you don't have exponential times
it's actually very unclear what typical
means
well there's a nice piece of work done
actually by Zealand Frank Purdue on
using gamma distributor waiting times
instead of explanation and the
especially for Arnold seems to be and so
on similar more complicated but similar
anyway we can discuss but I think we're
due for another discussion about our
note yes maybe next Monday okay yes that
should be great okay so let's talk about
corporate now I I know we talked a lot
uh this is the story so I'm not going to
say too much the details but December
31st well that's one officially we're
told of of this uh strange pneumonia
like illness that was spreading in Wuhan
and then they did the sequencing and
they found that it was actually caused
by Corona virus and it was spreading
rapidly within China initially and then
neighboring countries and within a few
weeks basically to all parts of the
world
and the who had to declare it a global
pandemic magic levels so this is an
important date I'm coming back to it
later March 8 levels and it's we so far
have lost about 6.6 million people it
represents the greatest Public Health
Challenge since the 1918-1919 pandemic
the H1N1 pandemic that hit particularly
Europe really badly
anyway so
yeah and it's it's a so there are a
group of RNA viruses that have been
causing diseases in in birds and mammals
you know and and the transition
transmission modes we talk about all
sort of
um but I want to highlight this the
chronology
cannot pronounce my own word chronology
of control measures uh so the spring of
2020 so the index case in the US was uh
brought in I think January 20th of 2020
here in the Bay Area I don't know which
particular
location
um anyway so basically what was
implemented at the time essentially was
combination lockdown followed by oh no
actually where is uh hamsai
it's called conservative what what's the
what he's taken by oh okay conservative
Community lockdown okay that's what
happens throughout most places yeah I
like that yeah conservative Community
log uh social distancing I'm asking
that's the spring mostly that was what
was implemented and in the summer and
masking and some social distancing and
then we got the vaccines uh to the the
two mRNA vaccines python Madonna
approved for use
given the emergency use authorization by
FDA in December of 2020 but by the time
they are deployed on large scale or
sometimes the spring of 2021 around
March I think
anyway so vaccination on some
non-pharmaceutical interventions right
so that's really the the main history uh
so the question I wanted to address is
okay could we have altered the
trajectory of the pandemic if we had
done certain things differently what did
we learn from the pandemic of course the
causing 623 million cases confirmed
cases globally and this is hugely
underestimated by the way even the CDC
acknowledged that uh because of the
problem of asymptomatic pre-symptomatic
cases uh transmission the the number of
cases we have uh purported cases is a
gross under estimation of the actual
cases so and that's why at the beginning
I think it
it makes a lot of sense to only use
mortality data to fit models for covet
rather than case data because case data
clearly I think the estimate why the CDC
is like 410 Ford lower than the actual
this is what the CDC director the
previous one said
as a test do we believe they are correct
or is that by 10 off by 50 by Factor two
the death I think that that's at the
beginning was not great also by using
later on the mortality data was very
reliable at the beginning yes they are
not counting those who died in
reservation care facilities and also
data Health later on I think a few
months later we got that
but the case data up to today definitely
not I mean you cannot detect unless we
do large-scale random testing there's no
way we can detect someone who is
asymptomatic and preset
I mean therefore the case data by
definition is just just not reliable
yeah okay
at least for covert for other like the
stars the first one yes case data was
very good because the people doing the
transmission are the symptomatic people
so the case data was very reliable 2002
but not this one anyway so this is
zoonotic and this is one of the main
things that I'll highlight throughout in
this talk uh covid-19 emerge out of box
to to to to to unpongle is maybe some
some intermediate horse but starting
from bats all the way to unbutz uh The
Usual Suspects for most of uh deadly
diseases largely because their immune
system is designed in such a way that
the good reservoirs for many terrible
diseases but the diseases don't kill
them
but then but I was given a lecture this
was an envirus a while back and then say
well why not just find a way to get rid
of all bats but then I I was told that
bats are very useful to the agricultural
economy like in Texas a lot like one
billion dollars or what's up the
droplets are very useful in so anyway
you mentioned the Batman movies you know
yeah that too yeah the movies also
Hollywood loves bats yeah okay yeah yeah
so anyway this is so so this is remarks
the one Middle Eastern respiratory
syndrome which emerged out of
um out of uh Jordan and Saudi Arabia in
2012 is still spreading through camel to
humans and this one the swine flu
remember the 2009 H1N1 started out of
Mexico and the United States right here
through the swine
or hey it's here you can say some more
on this and and yeah so all of the you
know this diseases this terrible
pandemic essentially uh emanated from
animal population malaria we didn't have
malaria until about 12 000 years ago
that's Malay the plasmodium has always
been around for millions of years but
spreading all the lizards and other
non-human primates it's only 12 000
years ago that plasmodium jumped into a
human form of malaria and the reason is
obvious because this is the beginning of
the last ice age the the world was
getting warmer and warmer like a
cultural civilization Opening Our
breeding habitats for all sorts of
diseases including malaria and that's so
the point out of this slide is to say
that if we're leaving them alone
if we're not encroaching their natural
habitat and destroying their natural
habitat pushing them away many of these
diseases that we'll be dealing with or
have been dealing with for decades will
not have happened but there will have
been just restricted to just zoonotic
diseases not human so it's anthropogenic
it's things we as humans do to the
natural environment to the ecosystem
that makes us vulnerable to all sorts of
diseases
yeah so it's a recombination of birds
and pangolins rays that Transmissions
through the uh the wet market so again
people tourism was mentioned uh
yesterday and today as well and it's
possible also it started by accidental
lick from some lab
we do not know for sure but bats are
implicated for for this uh what else
okay so
we've seen it's not the first time we've
seen coronavirus I've mentioned before
that at least two others before carbon
19. so this one the first one started
out on the Province in China 2002 2003
spread to 29 countries of course about
744 deaths globally Murs started out of
Saudi Arabia 27 countries but case
fatality ratio about 34 the good news
about the two is that they are not
what's lower even though they have huge
imagine if Corbett has case fatality
ratio of 34 my goodness
so 34 of people with symptoms will die I
mean that would have been wow it
probably more than the H1N1 pandemic of
1918 but luckily the case fatality was
initially about 2.5 to then it decreased
the two and now down to 1.1 we're
getting better and better on vaccination
playing a major role in in this as well
okay
all right so I would describe some
models um right you you sort of teased
and said what could we have done better
will you tell us that absolutely yeah
yeah that's the whole point I'm just
starting with this the presentation now
yeah I'll say that yeah
so yeah
sure
so this uh case fatality ratio I mean
people mix that up with the infection
fatality ratio so yeah the case fatality
ratio depends on also how many people uh
that had a disease that are tested
positive so yeah the risk of dying is
probably uh somewhat or fair amount
smaller than that so here so yeah so
what of the so here how I calculated
this this is a the number that died
let's say the 627 million are quite
confirmed cases globally but you said
it's probably a factor 10 larger so
actually so now 0.1 that's true that two
yeah yeah I should have done that yes
that's what he's saying yeah the case
this number is definitely lower than the
actual yes
yeah yeah I have comparison between the
r0 plus three yes so I think for starts
at the beginning
I so I studied science a lot actually
this at the beginning was like 1.2 1.3
less than two definitely and then when
we start and this was controllable in
the basic method almost all the modeling
groups predicted exactly the same thing
Neil Ferguson's group uh Marcus's group
uh however our group I was in Canada at
the time so we wrote A Royal Society
people everybody was saying SAS was a
disease that was controllable in basic
Public Health major just quarantine
isolation hand washing you didn't need
any promise or cultivation the reason
was because R naught was low and also
the main drivers were symptomatic people
people with symptoms and they are mostly
mostly younger people because older
people had prior immunity so so we we
quarantined in Canada at the time over
four million people were talking this
morning four million people were
quarantined in in
all country and I think it's mostly a
big problem within the greater Toronto
area but they are not for for for for
such anyway was um it was 1.5 at the
beginning 1.2 and then it quickly went
down to zero below one and it died out
within six months nine months that was
it but this was gone uh for Mars you
still have a student working on it it
was also very low
um not not nowhere near near two
so slightly above one and it came down
as well
and it's only spreading right now in two
countries in Jordan and Saudi Arabia and
it's largely to do with the camel
um writing that the host uh the camel
exercise they have the sports or
something like that so that's the
disease is ready in camel but then
because of proximity of humans and
camels the the harming cases so when
only as far as only in those two
countries but they are not yes Kobe the
one that came they are not initially
Neil Ferguson group estimated it to be
three to five
you know and that's at the beginning
so it's not much much higher even now
with Omicron of course it's much higher
or not because Omicron but it's not as
fatal so so yeah it depends on the yeah
so this is more contagious and that's
that's what the the main differences
between covid-19 and the other two is
first of all the role of asymptomatic
transmission and pre-symptomatic
transmission which was not the case for
the other two
people who are asymptomatically trans uh
infectious and presentable were not the
main drivers of the epidemic for the
other two but this one there I mean I'll
show you some data that shows that I
mean drivers and it's more transmissible
it has higher mode
essentially yeah
you mentioned that for the original
stars older people already had fired I
think so yeah some sort of
um
oh yeah so I said the original SAS the
older people have prior immunity yes I
think that's what's
some kind of coronavirus like it going
on around China before in in the past
yeah probably I don't like
I'm not sure but I know people have said
that yeah because most of the cases at
least we know in in Canada was mostly
younger people
I'm sorry oh no it's okay
not a very good question but
um so Poland did like a bunch of random
testing right like a national scale yeah
random like is that what people use to
estimate like the underest like that we
were 10x below or anything like that
like in terms of the number of cases or
deaths and is that consisted across I
guess I don't know previous
um epidemics had like such a large scale
testing regimen like is that consistent
the underestimated Ratio or whatever I
think it's possibly that uh but I know
well at least I know what we did what
some other groups have done is just to
fit the data the model was data and then
use that to see okay what of all those
new cases which ones are attributed by
fitting the transmission rate for
asymptomatic and pre-symptomatic and see
what's the proportion on Poland yeah
yeah got it yeah yeah exactly so okay
yeah sorry
I see so you said you I mean
not quite as fancy but you trained the
model on Poland data and then fitted the
world sorry no I didn't mean we use U.S
data sorry we didn't use
it no no so there's uscdc are the ones
who said actually the case data for the
US was grossly I guess the actual data
the CDC I didn't use a Poland sorry yeah
yeah Norris
okay
all right so this is a simple model we
can use for for covert but uh so it's a
sub tool will Expose and then we have
you become a pretty symptomatic IP and
then at the end of the symptomatic
period a proportion
R will show symptoms to go to is and
their minimum proportion will not show
symptoms and becoming asymptomatically
infectious at the red Sigma p in this
case so and then after that they
recovered red gamma a these ones will
recover at Red gamma s and this one will
be hospitalized right PS and and recover
and so on so it's a simple model and
this transmission rate so I just
highlight there are four sources of
infection I mean so someone in the
pre-symptomatic stage can transmit
someone in the asymptomatically
Infectious stage and the other one is
hospitalized at the beginning
hospitalized people who are transmitting
but later on of course they are not so
and symptomatic people are also
transmitted so four main routes of
infection if you are susceptible coming
within six feet of someone in the IP
class IA class is class and IH class can
result in infraction and the Deltas are
the disease in this mortality in the
S-Class and the hospitalized class so
people do not die in the pre-symptomatic
ending asymptomatic classes so again
this is a an epidemic model so the way
we formulated it there's no
uh there's no demographic so again the
time scale of the disease is assumed to
be much much shorter than the
demographic time scale so in the US for
example people live on average to be 79
years but for newer diseases we assume
that it's going to disappear within like
maybe two years something like that so
three compared to 79 is small so that's
why we do not include demographic at the
beginning but later on when we started
vaccinating kids and so on and disease
has been around for like two two years
already two and a half years but it
makes a lot of sense to include
demographics particularly because we're
vaccinating younger people
um so anyway so Lambda is the infection
rate the the
um and then you get infected so you move
so this basically the equation is based
on the floor diagram
okay so we fitted this model oh yeah
before that I okay so this is the
pre-lockdown and lockdown period and I'm
looking at three states on the entire
U.S Arizona State Arizona the State of
Arizona I would say at the time so we
want a lockdown very much uh on March
31st so and the first case was reported
March 6 for the state so between 6 March
6th or 31st we are not in lockdowns
that's called pre-lockdown period and
the lockdown period is that and we
reopen the economy May 15th
uh so then we become less conservative
uh locked down so we are a conservative
lockdown during that and then May 15th
we declared out anyway
yeah exactly so anyway this is Florida
it's the same thing and New York so
notice New York was the first to go on
lockdown uh March 22nd and they stayed
longer than everybody else until May
28th okay and then we estimated okay the
entire country okay maybe by April 7
pretty much the whole country was a
lockdown but we stayed on lockdown until
New York decided to yeah I mean that's
uh anyway in this paper that's what we
do so we fitted the model using data
available at the time pre-lockdown and
lockdown period
okay just simply Square regression
basically to fit the model okay and this
the top ones are the lockdown No
pre-lockdown period the cumulative depth
again during the early stages I was only
using mortality data because I thought
was more realistic and this is the
um the cumulative death uh for the four
locations or jurisdictions but the one
in the lockdown period so in either case
uh the fitting seems reasonable and we
use so in this model the only parameters
really we do not know for sure uh the
betas those four betas I think and
possibly maybe the Deltas the disease in
this mortality rate so we could fit the
model with the data to estimate find the
best values of these parameters that we
do not know that's the whole point of
fitting the model is data right the
estimate unknown parameters so we did
that
and uh and now we can make uh
predictions to help me obtain the best
values of those unknown parameters and
what we did was okay to say well if we
have fitted the model to obtain those
four parameters I would not know for
sure can we then go back to the model
with this fitted values and then run the
simulations of the daily cases and
compare with the observed daily cases to
see whether we do well it's a way of
validating our model and this is what we
we got here this is for Arizona this is
for Florida this New York the entire U.S
before lockdown on Dual lockdown and the
dots red dots are the data points and
this is for the daily cases so you see
all the uh it seems reasonable of course
it's not a perfect fit but it's the
reason we did better actually in New
York compared to other three uh
jurisdictions
but anyway it seems reasonable so we are
satisfied with uh so having fitted those
parameters now we can generate okay who
are the main drivers of the epidemic
among the four routes the
pre-symptomatic asymptomatic symptomatic
and hospitalized people so based on the
fitting we uh just calculated the
proportions so beta P divided by the sum
of all the weight Association so in
order to pre-lockdown period uh in
Arizona for example the pre-symptomatic
people accounted for about 47 of the new
cases
um based on uh parameterization and
asymptomatic was 19. so in the whole
Florida New York the entire U.S the same
so the conclusion is the main they can't
do for at least 70 percent of all new
cases those pre-symptomatic asymptomatic
People based on our data so they're the
main drivers of the epidemic and what
does this tell me okay well it tells us
straight away right from day one the the
most perhaps the most effective strategy
to use would be one that targets
detection of this pre-symptomatic and
asymptotic people and what will be that
strategy that strategy has to be testing
testing testing is clear but it has to
be large scale testing not just testing
people with symptoms there are no domain
drivers of the epidemic the main drivers
and I think it's still the same the main
drivers of the epidemic maybe not the
same percentages but it's still
increasing dramatic asymptomatic people
and the only way to know that because
they don't even know they are sick
themselves they don't even know they're
infected and they're mostly younger
people so the only way to detect them is
through large-scale testing and random
testing large-scale random testing
anyway so that's the first conclusion
okay and the second one is okay we
what's the impact of early lifting of
lockdown measures
oh that's a question sorry can you show
the previous slide please yeah of course
uh let's go back why is it that the
column us is give very different figures
from the three first columns
uh yeah so we fitted the entire us data
so we here we fitted the data for the
State of Arizona Florida New York this
is the whole previous so some places
didn't have a lot of covet cases in the
in the U.S or some states basically did
really well others didn't so on average
we're getting these numbers yeah
it's strange because it's very different
from yeah very different from well New
York was hit the hardest than any other
state but they they know about what he
seems to be saying is your us if you add
pre-lock and as Prismatic asthma check
out this is sort of around 60 and all
others are much larger so yeah is that
that The Californians made up for it and
we have much less possibly possible I
mean yeah yeah but still the same I mean
this accounting for at least 50 of all
new cases I mean even if that's that's a
huge even if we say just 50 of all new
cases are generated by people who have
no idea they have the disease
now how did you estimate those
proportions oh so using the data so so
we fit the model with the data for each
state so the betas are the parameters we
do not know so we estimated them you
minimizing the sum of squares basically
list squares and any other so I have a
question on your estimates you your
models so you using the sort of
very simple McCormick equation which is
differential and we sort yesterday and
some of us learned maybe a week before
that there is sort of the integral
equations and to assume that covet has
it has a time which looks like that this
case exponential rather than a peak and
which dies down after so how sensitive
is this actually to having an
exponential distributed
infection times
because that is super unrealistic that's
just that's probably the most
probabilistic assumption in your model
well yeah it's a simplified assumption
to say the washing time in each
compartment is exponentially distributed
but what I was arguing the work I've
seen in the past was gamma distribution
and some other distribution but let's
expression for R naught
tend to be and the fitting is much
better actually if you do gamma
distribution right so that but could you
have done this with gamma oh sure sure
sure in fact some of the later works
that we this was done like 2020 it's not
in the lockdown period this was like
June of 2020. so yeah later on we use uh
gamma distributed waiting time so yeah
do you have an idea about uh
Precision of your estimates I mean
yeah yeah we calculated those yes and
you can also compare how large of those
confidence intervals how large
you give data you don't give us the
confidence I know I did it yeah it's
plus or minus what uh two one five ten
no I I can't remember that yeah this one
was a long time ago I was just for me
when I saw this number that I was scared
my goodness is that really what's going
on that I saw other other groups as well
Ness group at RTL also came up with
similarities but that really surprised
me but anyway yeah
ascertainment ratio right because
asymptomatics of symptomatics you cannot
measure so you have to have some idea of
how much uh how many are they because
you only see cases right yeah you have
these cases
okay the question yeah so we only see
cases so how do you really estimate
asymptomatic Impressions from other
cases yeah because we only see cases
places are compound cases yeah they're
not pretty simple asymptomatic so uh so
what we did again we estimated just the
betas based on the data at that
particular point in time so we as we
think that the whole you know so all the
new cases are generated by the four
sources
symptomatic and hospitalized so all of
those things I've learned in the data
therefore if we use that data to
estimate beta p and beta n or that we
think that that captures in the estimate
in the privatization you only look at
the cases yeah or the fitting yeah all
these intervals you are on the on the
case look at the mortality data or
mortality yeah yeah not cases yeah I
mean look at the mortality yeah this is
based on 15
yeah
that's good
okay
well I should do the confidence in
double later on yeah
okay so now we made tradition what the
impact of alligator on lockdown with
this okay so conservative lockdown Okay
so
this is the feeling when we are in
lockdown the Shaded region is for
Florida access for New York remember New
York went in Ali and the stadium and the
blue is Baseline and right is the data
so the place like parameters and we
predicted what would happen actually
what we think would happen in Arizona if
we everything remain the same because we
lifted lockdown very early and we said
if nothing else changes
and this is the sort of data that we
predicted this was published sometimes
in August of 2020 2020 this paper
and that was the estimate we had for um
we got a lot of hit actually people who
are writers and how your doomsday
scenario is saying that terrible thing
but that's pretty almost precisely what
happened
in the fall of 2020 yeah so we hit we
didn't really have a first wave in
Arizona so we had the second way which
was massive
yeah because we lifted lockdown so early
the same thing in Florida but look at
New York
because it stayed longer they benefited
from that so the the second the third
wave was much milder compared to pretty
much everywhere else in the country this
is for the entire country so any any
case this is predicting that things was
going to get was if we continued on the
same trajectory
um
so then we looked at okay suppose we
um so so here uh yeah miles reopening so
if you were not conservative we really
openly if we are more liberal actually
no if we're more conservative opening so
which is mild we we do not say okay
after the day of lifting of lockdown you
can go to Russia you can do whatever you
want you don't have to mask up so that's
the conservative reopening but if you
smile down so on so it's a magenta color
and the green color so if it's mild
reopening a moderately we have seen very
different trajectories so the fact that
we lifted things immediately and didn't
really put a lot of restrictions uh that
was what it was responsible for this
terrible thing and we received quite a
bit of patreon at the beginning but
later on people have to write back and
eat up their Awards which was good I
mean
yeah I think was it depended on my
reopening meaning there's still a lot of
restrictions but you can probably go out
but maybe not go into a restaurant
indoors you can eat in the restaurant
but outdoors and away from people so we
have some criteria in the paper for what
Mile and mortar of your company is but
then you would have to do that in
definitely
we have to do it until a certain period
of time until we really suppress the
community transmission and buy ourselves
time until we get a vaccine yes that's
what we say not indefinitely but
suppress Community transmission because
that's a reason why we want to suppress
Community transmission also it minimize
the likelihood of development of uh or
emergence of new variants so you're so
your figures contradict a little talk by
Tom from the a little while ago so there
are people who studied what is optimal
policies for lockdown and things like
that and one of the things we learn from
those that if you do early lockdown
so if you do lockdown really at the
beginning before you have reached the
peak yeah all you do is you will you
delay hurt immunity and your curves you
never draw these curves to the end so it
could be that you would actually have a
second Peak if you lock down you will
sort of not have hurt immunity but you
still are in a region that are not as
big and it will stay big because you
have lockdown and then when you were
open you just get the same curve delayed
well you can delay yeah yeah so here so
I'm astonished I don't see that in your
picture sort of it should somewhere at
least for a little while it show should
show up if I locked down just in the
beginning for a short time you should
just if you do perfect lockdown you
should suppress yeah yeah but it may
come back up again if you do not
continue to right so you have to lock
down forever
well at least until the end of when we
know we're going to have it back on we
have a vaccine then you don't need to
lock that oh so are you assuming we
locked on until we have suffixes until
and we got the simulation until end of
the year end of 2020. so we didn't uh
but I'll show you okay next slide will
be much clearer I'll do another one
that's even more
more impressive I think uh so early
implemented okay so this one is to say
okay suppose we started lockdown like a
week earlier our two weeks earlier so
magenta is if we started looking down in
Arizona a week earlier than we did and
green dash line is if you started two
weeks earlier and then we stayed
lockdown until this duration until what
uh June of 2020 so so so that's so
basically just what
yeah anyway so
this is the this is why we're predicted
so you see instead of this this is what
actually happened this program the data
is right under blue is the Baseline even
Baseline values of our parameters which
fitted to the data reasonably well but
this is what would have happened if we
started locking down a week earlier than
we did uh this is two weeks earlier
along with it so this will help
suppressed epidemic
all especially in Florida in New York
and there are Soviets are preachable
epidemic in Arizona and in the entire
U.S if we
if we did this so it's early
implementation so hit hard and hit early
would have saved a lot of lives and this
is what this slide is showing if we
started just a week earlier the really
is because you know uh
at this rate I really want to correct
you if you start a week earlier and
don't stop if you start a week earlier
and actually stop a week earlier I think
calculations show you get more this not
less steps
more depth if you so if you want to
reduce the number of deaths to a minimum
you should actually start at the peak
but that's only if you if you give
yourself only let's say two months if
you give yourself until you have the
vaccine I agree with you yeah so what
here we didn't start to pick we just
said well suppose we started our
simulations like locking down with all
these parameters locking down means okay
how do you implement lockdown it
minimizes your contacts okay so the
betas are reduced by a certain scale
that we spaced by at the beginning if
that was implemented a week earlier or
two weeks earlier this is a trajectory
of the disease we have this is we will
still have a peek here but it's much
milder than compared to what happened
over there so the mortality would have
been suppressed uh greatly if we do if
we do it that way anyway okay so what
else so what about masking so now that
was locked down if we started locking
down early and stayed a little longer we
could have saved a lot of lives
um this is masking so we here we have
data for the three waves and we fitted
the data cumulative mortality
um right is data blue is the model uh
this is the daily mortality also so we
fitted the model here and then use the
fitter parameters to predict or to see
whether or not our model matches the
daily of the application this is not
easy to do actually because
three different ways but somehow it
looks reasonable under some of the
papers here
the question we wanted to address okay
well suppose masking is the only
strategy we have
nothing else we're not locking down
conservative or not I like that one uh
suppose we all leave masking can we can
we can we do much better if we have done
something slightly different if if the
strategy is just based on asking alone
okay so let me show you so here so we
run simulations what's the impact of Ali
implementation on masking strategy okay
so and this is
okay so here we we started masking four
days after the who declared covet to be
and this is only for the United States
to be a global pandemic so on March 15th
March 11th was the Declaration by who so
if we started masking and then we'd have
different types of masks okay there are
four different types of masks either
close masks which has efficacy about 30
essentially improved one which is about
50 applications and the surgical mask
nobody's wearing surgical mask here no
okay it's about 70 and then the n95 mask
that run is wearing so it's green okay
so if we started just four days after
this is what we predicted this is the
Baseline the blue and this is what would
have happened in terms of cumulative
mortality if you use if majority of the
people 80 of the population wear a mask
every time they are in public
and if the mask you'll be prioritize
only the cloth mask which is basically
ineffective one so you see that there's
some Savings in mortality compared to
the Baseline but it's not very
significant compared to if every one of
80 that go out where n95 masks
if we're all okay so four days after who
has declared a pandemic if 85 80 of us
go up every time we go out we wear n95
mask and correctly of course we know the
Tight Seal and all that this is what we
predict in the pandemic habit
huge savings in terms of mortality and
this one is if we started uh this one I
think is if we started on 18th of
February which is like two months after
the index case in the United States
yes sir
um
in terms of the models how the masking
effect and the lockdown uh different in
the models how is the masking effect on
the lockdown I mean where are the
parameters coming to the models well the
problem okay so here we have two
different types of model that's one
model which is stratified the population
as a group model those who wear masks
consistently when they go out and those
who do not so the the first paper I
showed the mask or not to mask paper
this one partner is a group structured
model okay with that but the other one
is just masking is to reduce your
probability of transmission it has two
main efficacies right mask is the inward
efficacy if I'm susceptible wearing a
mask it protects me from getting
infected if I come within six weeks or
somebody was impacted so it has the
inward efficacy but it also had the
outward efficacy if I'm infected and
wearing a mask my probability of
transmitting to you if you are
susceptible in your within six feet is
reduced so that's how we met so it's in
reduction in my contagion capacity or
ability to get the disease so it's we
modify the betas by just putting this
because the follow-up question so you're
social distancing would just be a
perfect mask
essentially yeah yeah essentially if
it's but then the question of social is
that's a study which is not six feet and
the optimal distance is uh there's this
um
lockdown lockdown is a perfect mask
well it depends if it's perfect lockdown
also yeah lockdown is above if you stay
at home yeah yeah if you don't go out
because you may go to lockdown we saw
how to go to the grocery stores do
certain things right yeah but your model
didn't have that right you assume
perfect lockdown now this one here when
you showed us the data did you assume
that you have one percent Lee Kitchen in
the simulations yeah the lockdown was
not perfect oh yeah yeah I see so what
percentage did you assume I cannot
remember the percentage but yeah the
lockdown was not perfect because people
in lockdown you still have to go do
groceries you have to still there's
emergency service people who have to
still be out in the street doing
something so that we accounted for for
that I do not remember the exact figure
for that yeah but there's no such thing
as well except in Wuhan actually had
almost perfect lockdown nobody was
really going out so they had a way to
deliver food to people like
in a room wouldn't transfer
oh yeah that's that's a very good
question also yeah we didn't account for
that in the model but I know I agree
with you that I think even the lockdown
didn't work perfectly because yeah of
course yeah no I like that yeah thanks
okay so if we started again if we
started like uh two months even two
months earlier this is what we predicted
the point is if we be all using n95 the
disease would have basically failed to
take off
even if we started like two months
earlier two months after the index case
of the United States you know if
everybody is so what we're saying now if
you stockpile n95 masks and make them
available to everybody who are in the
next pandemic yeah and if everybody
wears that we do not even have shut down
the economy that's no need for lockdown
this has no lockdown this model just all
we have is it does this using this mask
so what's your assumption of I'm not so
for example now I'm not supportlessly to
be 20 so an n95 just gets on not to one
and if it's not fair perfectly it will
not quite help
every time they go out so if you have 80
percent that would just sort of it would
just reduce or not to 20 so if I'm not
this 10 it's still two
well here so we're looking at cumulative
mortality so it's not cases so so but
mortality that was for sure I'm not in
this I don't remember what the answer
was yes but I can check that quickly but
I I don't know what it whatever it is
it's definitely a surprise because not a
lot of people are dying there may be a
lot of cases like we're seeing now is
Omicron a lot of cases but mortality
nowadays is definitely not what we used
to get I mean we used to have like 3 000
people die in the US every day
so nowadays it's what maybe 100 maximum
does anybody know what the mortality
data is for
now it is
more than 100 I think by the way we are
slowly running out of time like oh very
fast I have to okay I have to I have a
lot more stuff to do okay uh quickly so
I'll give you well I will I have a
meeting I have to run to so I will give
this microphone to I mean I mean
here's my friend he's going to give me a
lot of time yeah
okay I take back what I just said I
thought it's less than 100 a day yeah
but it's still compared to three
thousand messages
you suggested
a good I mean what uh and the 95 mask
would be perfect but but are you sure
that for the next pandemic this will be
the good tool no if it is a respiratory
passage you're like oh but yeah if it's
a pandemic of respiratory infection yeah
that is spread through the respiratory
droplets yes but we have no idea what
the next one could be Ebola which is
contact based and I mean it could be
Ebola could be so but if it's
respiratory if it's covered like
pandemic then yes this will be fantastic
uh tool to do it we do not have to shut
down the economy at all if everybody
wears n95 mask correctly and
consistently yes sorry
question you can repeat the question yes
you were looking at controlling
mortality right yes but what if you
control infections cases is that the
same uh we didn't check that that's a
great point we're looking and these
figures are comparing mortality or
checking in Savings in terms of
mortality what percentage of people the
one million people that have died what
how many of them would have affect them
so um
well yeah so so what this is correlated
with software capacity because most of
the people are dying crosswords
okay all right now the game changer
moment uh this Grandma uh Margaret
Keenan the first person to receive a
covered vaccine in the United Kingdom
yeah change the moment in the world the
MRNA vaccines approved for use
by FDA and around also I think she got a
fighter vaccine although quite a large
number of people get the Australia but
she got the Piezo one there's a very
first case
in the UK anyway that changed the whole
landscape uh it was great uh the whole
point of mRNA vaccines the strategy or
the solution process has been going on
for decades in like three to four
decades actually people have been
working on this they built a platform
and uh luckily
what anyway
so these are the vaccines the efficacies
are the dose stretcher the structure
boosters and all of that anyway so I
think we all
so I probably wouldn't go into too much
detail because of time
huh
but these are the four boxes that are
been used in the U.S so
an AstraZeneca is used around the world
but I think not here
in the U.S right yes sir
efficacy because oh okay so I think
there are two types of efficacies okay
so here uh so the efficacy of the
vaccine is measured in two ways one it
one the pharmaceutical people talk about
efficacy what they're talking about is
efficacy against severe disease
hospitalization or death that's what
they mean but here in our context in
modeling is efficacy to protect a
vaccinated person from acquiring
infection in the first place so there
are two main types of the protective
efficacy there's also the therapeutic
efficacy so therapy so when they say
it's 80 so what almost all of these
vaccines are 85 efficacious with respect
to therapy so if you got it you have 85
chance of not developing severe disease
85 chance of not getting hospitalized
and 85 chance of not dying if you got
the vaccine any of the I don't know
about novelworks but any of the three
that have been used in the USA it had
those fantastic that in fact covered
after the vaccination was implemented uh
became now the disease of the
unvaccinated people so if you're
vaccinated the chances are you you won't
get infected even if you do get the
brexit infection you're not going to
develop severe disease and you're not
likely going to be hospitalized and
you're certainly not likely to be to die
of covert well that's a that's a great
question yeah so so they're highly
education so I I don't remember the last
time we had a vaccine that's this 95
percent maybe measles vaccines yes maybe
human papilloma virus works well I don't
know of any other vaccine that has this
does anybody know any that has this
level of efficacy
yeah
um so I think we should let Bob finish
oh sorry okay okay
yeah okay all right so variants that's
another great thing that happened with
respect to Corbett actually this uh
genomic surveillance around the world
particularly in Israel in South Africa
in in the UK uh until they've done
fantastic job in Germany also uh genomic
surveillance Omicron was detected by the
genomic surveillance team in South
Africa actually and they may have saved
the world of disaster actually by by
telling us about Omicron ahead of time
um that was really great so
anyway and this is the data for uh
case data daily so in the US we already
we had about 100 million compound cases
which maybe multiply that by four at
least
and also unfortunately over 1 million
people have died since I've had multiple
the daily cases this daily mortality and
this is when Delta hits this is the
region when Delta was the only game in
town and it was displayed or displaced
by Omicron
um sometimes in the fall of uh last year
anyway so we wanted to
um to to model this uh and this is hard
immunity but I think I'll skip this uh I
think everybody knows what it means but
Tom is here so I should mention oh
anyway so we we did a model of
vaccination the same pretty much at the
previous model but now we added
demographics because we're vaccinating
uh younger people or children as uh
children six months and older I think
anyway the same force of infection but
this is the vaccination rate so
vaccinated unvaccinated Su as we are
vaccinated susceptibles so here we have
differential susceptibility and
absolutely the efficacy of the vaccine
to protect you from getting infected so
it's a number between zero and one uh so
if it's one then there's no breaks
through infection you don't get infected
if you're vaccinated anyway so the same
the rest of it is the same but now uh if
if you recover so so that's the
demographic parameters are included Pi
Lambda and mu are included in this model
okay and then we fitted the model this
is dwell in the Omicron one on the
Chrome started so we fitted the model
and in part we have data up to here but
we was held one month of the data
to use okay so we fit it up to here but
then we sell one month of the data that
we already have for cross-validation
purposes so basically we're training the
model here to see whether or not it can
you know produce or it can capture this
one month of data that we already have
so it's called cross validation and it
works nicely and therefore we can make
prediction and this is why we predicted
it was Omicron it was basically going to
down out by sometimes much of this year
and pretty much it was going down so and
this is the cumulative cases uh in this
case here we use case data so
okay so we calculated our not for this
model it's not our not it's RC because
we're vaccinated people so it's given by
this so it just reduces R naught by this
a factor of 1 minus Epsilon b f b
Epsilon B is efficacy and FV is a
proportion vaccinated at steady state
okay so if Epsilon b f b is one of
course then that is essentially dies out
right
they we are you if everybody is
vaccinated and we have a vaccine that's
100 efficacious then the disease has no
chance it's gone and we calculated the
heart immunity threshold this is for
homogeneously mixed population so you
just set this equal to one that's a
verification point and then you solve
for the proportion you have to be that's
vaccinated and studies and that's a
classical definition uh party
Administration for homogeneous Olympics
population and then you can write your
resistary equilibrium uh local
asymptotics to voltage in terms of the
saree Administration which is given by
The Artsy leather one you have a chance
to control the disease uh greater than
one that this will persist
um fantastic paper about like Tom
Britton on on this uh if you do not have
a homogeneous if you have heterogeneous
mixing the Hardy ministration it's more
a lot more complicated than this and in
fact the requirement for hard immunity
is lower compared to when you have
homogeneous Linux population we followed
up on that and actually wrote a paper uh
looking at more theoretical
aspect of this but same idea essentially
Okay so
I have to stop now
okay well let me just go like you have
to give me this one minute that's okay
what will we do differently conclusion
I'm the organizer yeah okay yeah yeah so
these are the conclusions but what would
we have done different how to make it
the next one address the problem from
The Source let's get anthropogenic
climate change okay habitat distraction
all of those things that make it as
vulnerable to getting busy getting in
contact with wild animals and so on
doing all this terrible things that we
as humans do to the natural environment
address the problem from The Roots so
unless we address the problem of climate
change of Landings changes uh Wildlife
farming and all of the things we're
going to continuously be introduced to
new deadly diseases so realm of genomic
surveillance we have to be doing that a
lot of that we discussed that during a
break I think Greg we're talking about
yeah the need for surveillance genomic
surveillance testing people randomly to
see whether there's something going on
uh in the community before the CDC is
aware that it's already an outbreak so
early detection of respiratory pathogens
of course pandemic potential uh
stockpile and early deployment of Highly
Effective Mass
make them available and make them
available to everybody at the beginning
so
and what else Alia permutation effective
control but just lockdown should be
implemented early and for optimal
duration
so Wuhan did it for seven to six days
fantastic 76 days it worked but it was
real lockdown conservative conservative
lockdown in Ohio
okay Ali implementation of masking using
n95 or equivalent so there are masks but
they're also masks if we prioritize n95
make them below this would have we would
not even need to lock down we would not
need to shut down the economy at all if
everybody or majority of us in public
are using n95 this is what we have shown
uh Public Health messaging of course the
counter misinformation this information
so we need that we really have to do
that and I'm glad we're having this
workshop on misinformation information
degree
free at home rapid tests make them
highly effective DNA type tests now
people can do at home to test themselves
because that's the only way we can
detect asymptomatic pre-symptomatic
people and they're the main drivers of
this epidemic so unless we have large
scale testing that people can use at
home for example or a random large-scale
random testing we may not be able to
detect as simple as I'm pretty
symptomatic and they are the main
drivers of the epidemi all right improve
the efficacy of the MRNA vaccine well
they're already 95 personification so we
may not need to do that economic
incentives so we talked about I think
yesterday about the mid-factory workers
who even though they know they are
risking their lives to have to go to
work but they have to do that because
that only source of livelihood they have
to take care of their families so we
have to provide incentives for people
like that so that they can stay at home
with art so one health approach to
Public Health so not Public Health just
focusing on humans no humans and animals
and the environment one health approach
and despite doing all this hope that the
next one is not going to be as
contagious as Omicron and as deadly as
Delta so we still have to hope
despite all of those things so I yeah
we've seen this movie before
see what's in this we've talked about
Corbin now look at all this deadly
diseases we've seen in history human
history killing large number of people
and other outbreaks
they are all the nurses they're all
jumping from animal populations to
humans we have seen this movie before
this terrible movie before and most of
these are originated so we had since the
1980s I mean outbreaks of deadly
diseases this kind of diseases increases
on anti-aging Each decade is like three
times the previous one the number of
arteries some we know some we do not
know so the number of new outbreaks are
increasing at an alarm rate and they are
mostly about 70 75 percent are
originated from animal population
it's things we do to the animal
populations that makes us vulnerable
okay yeah so the consequences are
continued interference with natural
ecosystems destruction of habitats
deforestation Agriculture and all of
these things uh okay I see I mean it's
raising also I have to stop here and uh
thank you for your time but this is the
whole picture yeah
okay thank you bye
foreign
[Music]